have we done it
are we live I think we're live yes we've
done it
welcome back guys welcome welcome
welcome back welcome back to yet another
live stream VFX
episode today we are doing something a
little bit different you know I heard
you guys in discord channel you guys
want to learn how to take some you know
some CG stuff basically right and put it
into a live action scene that you had
filmed with you know your camera phone
or your a7r - you know what whatever
you're filming on you want to put some
CG stuff into that live-action footage
and that's what we're doing today so as
usual I have snacks I'm going with the
roasted garlic hummus this time the
pretzel crisps these things are the best
and I am the biggest fan of kombucha and
we got some cayenne kombucha here it's
spicy I feel like I'm getting healthier
with every single sip so some little
little extra special today um I figured
out how to finally enable I don't know
what this thing is super chat Oh super
chat yes I have enabled super chat a
super jet and usually I would be pushing
you guys to let's see my website here to
help out and support if you guys are
feeling if you guys are feeling nice but
yes I am selling prints here but you
know they are 40 bucks at least 40 bucks
a piece and I understand that it's a
little pricey for some of you guys so
instead of that we got the little super
chat going here and that's a way for you
guys to you know donate just the tiniest
amount if you guys are feeling
in the mood but it's it's there you
don't have to do it it's super
appreciated if you do but I just figured
I'd have to at least tell you guys I
enabled that finally cuz to be honest
with you guys I don't really know that
much about YouTube it's been five years
since I posted a video it's been far too
long so I'm learning guys I'm learning
how to make this thing better so
hopefully stream by stream
it'll get better and cooler and yeah the
super chats a fun way for us to interact
and like an extra-special way but yeah
dude Justin Justin is in the chat guys
justin is one of my very very good
friends he's like I don't know anytime
hang out Justin I just had the biggest
smile on my face and like we're into the
same games the same freaking humor the
same goofy stuff we play Smash Bros
together and he's incredible justin is
like doing the last thing I saw Justin
do was like some really cool like
miniature stop-motion Dark Souls stuff
and if you guys are a fan of Dark Souls
you'd be very impressed by that video
and Justin feel free to leave that link
down in the this little description here
I thought it was so cool but yeah guys
we got it we got people from around the
world here let's see Swank's tur norway
ooh
Dyan he's from India and sake I think
I'm saying that right both both you guys
for India Melanie from Finland
mr. Charles you are from the Netherlands
Kristoff hopefully the weather's nice in
Mountain View California and miroslav
from the Czech Republic where are you
where are you guys from we got a whole
lot of people from around the world I
think it's freaking awesome
but yeah you guys are you guys are great
thank you thank you for joining this
chat this livestream rather let's hop in
let us hop in so let's see hopefully you
guys yep
see this little screen here and what
I've done is just recorded a little bit
of footage at my house with my a7r - and
we're gonna track this thing and
after-effects and it's like the easiest
process guys here's the thing this is
gonna be so easy it's gonna blow your
mind and like this is what we did for
the Boston Dynamics video if you guys
haven't seen the math on dynamics video
most time dynamics yeah so we did this
video right and the robot is myself and
a motion capture suit I modeled the
robot textured the robot and this first
shot right here is just a shot of Jake
and Niko walking down the gun range
right and I believe you know we use the
couple programs for this right
it was mostly I mean After Effects for
compositing and cinema 4d for the
modeling texturing rendering and I know
Ren Ren is the track master he's also
the compositing master and Ren
when in doubt we'll switch to boo zoo
and boo zoo is this crazy weird program
whereas boo I know it yeah here it is
it's this crazy old program that 3d
tracks your footage in a very advanced
way and when in doubt when after effects
when the automated tracker doesn't work
in After Effects I go to boos you and I
do it in boos you and the program is
built for tracking live-action footage
and it has a lot of tools that After
Effects doesn't have to you know assist
you in things when things go wrong right
but we're not gonna be talking about
boos you today because no one has Buju
I'm sure there's some free 3d match
moving or tracking software around but
the one that I use and use most often
like you know for this
right here pretty sure I just used
after-effects the after-effects tracker
and it's like the greatest thing ever so
you can see here check this out like
this is just an automated track and I
even have a little zoom in there and it
tracks it perfectly the perspective is
correct
there's no jiggle or warble it just
works
and you'll notice too that the raw
footage it doesn't have any tracking
markers either and you know let's say
you're doing a little little video for a
client or something and they're like
well aren't you supposed to throw
tracking markers down you know you got
to have those little plus signs a little
tape you know you make little plus signs
and stick them everywhere right well
yeah sometimes but most of the times not
really because look look at all the
tracking detail in here look at this
carpet that's look at all the tracking
detail that's a whole bunch look at the
floor that's a bunch of tracking detail
same for this little cat scratcher post
that's this is all just glorious
tracking detail that you don't need
tracking markers because guess what if
you were to put tracking markers in the
scene you get the paint them out or
you'd have to know oh yeah I'm gonna be
putting um you know say like a little CG
RC car right here and the RC car is
gonna be on top of the tracking marker
so I wouldn't have to paint out the
tracking marker because I know that's
gonna be an RC car on top of that you
know that's if you have some insight
going into your shot but what you should
which you you certainly should but look
at this guys you don't need to throw
down tracking markers when in doubt this
is a good this is another Ren tip here a
pro Ren tip and he taught me that if you
basically add an unsharp mask to your
footage um let's see let's do a radius
let's see is it radius 50 yeah if you do
like a radius of like let's say for this
shot 200 right you see how things start
to get more contrasty if I were to turn
this on and off come in here like on
this carpet if I turn this on and off
you see it adds contrast and detail like
even the wood right here same deal
that's basically saying hey look here's
more tracking points for me to look at
here's more high contrast areas for me
to recognize as you know 3d space so you
duplicate the unsharp mask two more
times and you start to walk down your
settings on the radius until you have
something that looks pretty ugly right
but the point is for tracking your
adding contrast for tracking right
that's before and it when you turn it
off it kind of looks like there's like
some like angelic effect on it but so it
messes with your eyes a little bit but
that's with it on and if you pre-comp
your footage if you hit ctrl shift C
you'll pre-comp your footage of this
little window and you'll want to leave
all the attributes in that folder you're
basically putting it into a folder then
you run your 3d tracker oh I'm sorry I
got that wrong you're going to want to
move all the attributes into the new
composition and that moves all the
effects like you're unsharp mask into
that composition and once you have that
then you can run the 3d tracker on top
of your pre copier and just for you just
for you guys who forget the ctrl shift C
hotkey which you know learn learn those
hotkeys because that's how you can start
blazing through these programs but if
you go up to layer and at the bottom you
got precompose and that'll just put it
into a folder so I didn't even need to
add the unsharp mask to track this
footage it just worked so I'll do it
with you guys let's delete it and we got
our raw footage here alright all you
need to do is go to well there's a
couple ways to do this right because
it's another thing we learned is there's
like a million ways to do you know one
thing which can be confusing at times
but also it's it's great you know it
adds a little bit to the character you
know of how you go about your VFX but
let's let's add this tracker and then
let's answer some questions
in the chat here so basically if you
have VC console which is free you just
hit control space and that is your
effects bar that you're gonna search
right here right it's literally the
greatest plug-in ever
it's from Video Copilot called VC
console you hit control space and you
search camera tracker and you add it and
it'll it'll start going automatically
another way of doing that is to select
your footage go to effect and go to
where would it be guys where would it be
where were the was it who I have never
used this effects window here this drop
down in probably like five years so it's
in here somewhere guys you just have to
find it or you could select your footage
and you could let's see in After Effects
you have different like window setups so
that's up top here you can go to effects
and that should bring up the effects and
presets tab right here and in the
effects and presets tab you could also
type in what you're looking for camera
3d camera tracker that's what you want
it's under perspective so it's like your
footage go to effect go down to
perspective and hit the 3d camera
tracker and it's just gonna start going
now this is a special case right because
you saw that I had a little zoom at the
end of the footage so you need to tell
the 3d tracker that there's a zoom in
there so under shot type you're gonna
want to click that little drop-down box
and click variable zoom and that just
tells the tracker that hey I'm not just
looking at a fixed focal distance here
I'm looking I'm looking at something
that is actually you know zooming in a
little bit and it's just gonna do a more
accurate job of solving this problem
usually I'll hit this little drop
down here the advanced drop-down and
I'll check the detailed analysis box and
that's just like insurance for me to
know that you know I did everything I
could I put in all my chips on this you
know that little check box so that's
gonna go you'll see you'll see it doing
its little Deeley up here we got four
minutes left so while that's going let's
let's answer some questions if you guys
have any questions any any comments or
concerns but let's let's see what's
going down
Eric B says before we start what are
some tips for B for being a beginner
because I need to make something for a
school project and I'm pretty stressed
about it
okay well Eric I mean okay so tips on
being a beginner and you're doing a
school project that you're stressed
about we're talking about the effects
are you talking about like writing a
report because those are those are two
different things you know if we're
getting into the technical details of it
but if you want to talk generally which
I think apply to both um I would say
anytime I do something that seems big or
seems challenging right out the gates
what I'll do is first I'll stress out
about it and then I'll procrastinate a
bit and then eventually I come on Clint
get it in here let's do this thing and
you know you basically just have to
start biting off little pieces at a time
yeah you know you're not gonna be able
to run a full marathon just right out
the gates you're gonna have to bite off
little pieces and practice for it right
so what puts me at ease is hopping into
a project that seems daunting just
putting in an hour a day or an hour an
evening or an hour in the morning and
I'll chip away at it like my website
right I knew I wanted to sell prints and
I knew I wanted to have a place that I
could you know post all my photography
work that wasn't Instagram and it was
very daunting for me because I had never
made a website before and I was like
well what do I do and you know after
stressing out about it and freaked
and not really knowing what to do I was
just like you know what I'll just
dedicate an hour of my time this morning
to google searching what how to make a
website and that eventually led me down
to you know the next day where I spent
the next hour and I had a little bit
more information from the first day so
just baby steps bite off small pieces
work at it every day because if you
don't work at it every day
eventually you get to the point where
it's due and now you're really stressed
out but they would use Google man
Google's the best it will answer lots of
questions you may have
all right we got Michael from Germany
welcome Brody from Canada I'm a big
Canada fan I've been there a few times I
really love it welcome I came from
Russia Thank You Mendo studios from
Nigeria dude this is awesome you guys
were everywhere
lived in Burbank case in two to eight
lived in Burbank for a bit working in
film but moved to Florida welcome Rob
out from Dutch Caribbean welcome you
guys are awesome
Zorin Prince come on great stock details
are preserved really well so you really
get a sequence work yay thank you I'm
glad you enjoyed your print that's
awesome
I hope you enjoyed the music
recommendations as well so on toast from
India we got someone Zorin from Virginia
spill grouping from Sweden this is
awesome guys Sven from Germany man this
is this is awesome what an international
group we got here this is so cool I love
freakin love traveling and I know Justin
does too and we get down on traveling
and Justin literally has the size of
this Walt like his whole wall is just a
freaking map of the world it's so cool
and he just got back from a trip from
somewhere and I was about to go
somewhere and we were like showing like
plotting our courses and stuff it was
super cool but yeah I love traveling so
much and my dream is to travel and
travel the world and make it out to a
new country every single year so
hopefully I'll be coming
to all those places but damn guys you
got leave it a lot of comments this is
awesome
hey Clint how's it going it's great it's
going really well
um Seamus thanks for asking um can't
okay so case in two - wait a scamp
boosting the contrast also increase the
noise which can throw off the track um
not really maybe that's a really dark
scene and your noise is really high
potentially yeah but what's cool with
the unsharp mask is that you can tweak
the settings and tell it to add contrast
to a larger area that's when you
increase the radius as opposed to tiny
areas and yeah I might it might increase
a little bit of noise but that's never
been an issue for me ever you know and
and I haven't even tried to track night
footage and unsharp mask on night
footage but you know I I really don't
think it's that big of a deal um let's
see what else what else I'm trying to
reel these comments are so many I really
appreciate you guys does After Effects
require information about the camera to
do 3d tracking it does not but you know
like I said about that zoom technically
yeah that's that's information about
that's not information about the camera
it's information about the shot you can
add let's see you can specify it you
specify your angle of view and if you
shot at a 24 you can say I shot it at a
24 and I think that that will always
help the program to you know solve the
problem solve the track a little bit
better but yeah most of the time it's
not really needed this this thing works
really fast and it's pretty strong um
all right all right all right so you
guys are awesome thank you so much for
for leaving these comments here
hopefully we are 90 for you guys it's
freaking sick we're gonna SiC let's get
back to it guys keep the comments coming
I'll come back to him in a minute but
let's let's keep jumping in here
so we tractor scene boat it looks the
same right how do we know we did
anything so go ahead and click this 3d
camera tracker tab up here and still
nothing happens
where's our data where's our track we'll
try clicking this button right here the
toggle mask and shape path visibility
and there you go that's gonna show you
all the little points of your track here
and if you want to make this little bit
bigger you can go to the track point
size not so those guys at the 200 and
now you're seeing like they're changing
all over the place but that's okay it
looks like we got a lot of tracking
points so that's a nice juicy shot right
here we tracked it it works really well
average error right here says 2.5 pixels
that's that's not bad I think don't
really know what that means but 2.5
pixels is 2.05 pixels is probably pretty
good because this is a 4k shot and
that's a lot of pixels so one of my
favorite shortcuts is ctrl shift H and
that hides all the crap on your screen
and brings it up when you need it so
I'll be using that a lot alright so
you're gonna click the 3d camera tracker
effect up here and that's going to bring
up your little your little track points
and what we're gonna what we want to do
is make a 3d camera let's pretend those
don't exist we want to make a 3d camera
and we want to put down a null object or
a plane right here on the ground because
we're gonna go in to see 4d after this
and you know put put something in there
so let's select a few points here I'm
gonna click one over here hold down ctrl
click one over here still holding ctrl
I'll click one in the far corner and
then I'll do another one over here so
I'm covering a large area and I know
that I want to put something right in
the middle of that so what I'll do is
I'll right-click and you have some
options here you can create text in a
camera right so you can come in here and
say hello
and it's gonna be tracked in you can
select those points again all right and
you can make a solid for example instead
of text you can make a solid and that
solid is gonna be laid flat on the
ground right there and I'll actually hit
R I'm sorry not R I'm gonna hit W and W
brings up a rotation tool and that's up
here in the top left and we'll rotate on
the z axis so that our let's see our Z
plane which is forward and back right
lines up with this wall here and you can
see on the right it kind of lines up
with the couch in this litter box too so
I'm gonna hit R and then I'll bring up
your rotation settings for the layer
down below in the layers window and if
you hold ctrl while clicking and moving
some of these numbers down here
basically what you're doing is you're
kind of like it's like when you play an
FPS and you have like the what is it
like the the aim-assist
and it slows down the sensitivity of
your move your mouse it's like that when
you hold ctrl those real small numbers
stay real small numbers so you can have
a lot of control but let's say you want
to max it out right and you're trying to
just friggin spin this thing all crazy
doing it normally would get you this you
know but if you really want to go to
town you hold shift and that is the
opposite of holding control it goes way
faster and this is really handy for when
like you have something like a 3d layer
we're just way far out in 3d space and
these numbers are cranked to like
thousands and thousands right that would
be will be helpful holding shift but in
our case we can hold ctrl to really dial
in the rotation there and this is
looking good to me and how do we know if
it was a good track well another thing I
learned from Ren was basically what
you're gonna do here is give it a
effect and the grid effect will just
give you a transparent grid that you can
preview your shot with and really look
at all the points and angles to see if
this thing is tracked properly so grid
where would the grid be it'd be under
generate so if you go to effect and
generate where's generate where are you
generate Oh Mike this is so embarrassing
guys I don't use this window generate
there you are and you can go down to
grid and adds a grid let's take the
border up to like 25 so we can really
see what's going on make sure you guys
save your work my goodness save your
work save your work let's do a little
preview answer some questions here how's
everybody doing what films by looking
forward to this year Christopher Nolan's
new film I'm actually really excited for
that I hadn't seen a trailer but I like
to keep it that way I like to be
surprised not know what I'm getting into
um I don't know as David Fincher making
a movie this year I hope so he's one of
my favorite directors other than that
like I don't know man like not really an
Avengers fan or Marvel or superhero fans
so I can't say I'm looking forward to
any of those David welcome better late
than never dude do you measure your
scene for match moving work or do you
have to find other ways to scale so what
he's asking what David's asking is uh do
you have to bust out the measuring tape
you know and usually no we don't do that
but for Boston Dynamics we did so
basically for the first one let's see if
I can pull up the first one here
what we did was we measured this room
here this loading dock and Ren actually
Ren measured the whole thing and Ren
modeled this loading dock in 3d so it
was actually like perfectly accurate
down to the inch right and the reason we
did that is because we knew we had to
track the scene to add the robot in
right so the way to test your track and
the way to make sure that the robot is
actually being lit properly too is to
put it in this room right and you see
there's a little light up here we had to
add that light as well right there's a
light up here so we had to add that
light as well and it was very important
that we modeled this room down to the
exact measurements because one for
lighting and two for camera tracking we
had to make sure that our track was
perfect and we would reference it we
would essentially like put it up against
the the footage with the the CG room and
if the two of those lined up perfectly
then we knew we were set but in this
case no I'm not I don't need to bust out
any measurements or anything you know
it's just it's just working it's working
nice and good that zoom is great so once
you have this once you guys have your
track right all you need to do and I'm
going into cinema 4d you can do this for
for blender or 3ds max but basically I'm
gonna export this camera data into
cinema 4d so let me open up cinema real
quick Ryan welcome welcome welcome
Topher tell Ryan I said hey alright I'll
make sure to do that
I made his 3d mograph title thousand
ways to kill a noob do that was a long
time ago heck yeah that's great
Oh a new Pixar movie
oh man Pixar is literally the best the
absolute best they are the kings of
story I'm amped for that and heck yeah
super amped for that alright let's see
let us see how do I feel about Joshua
asks how I feel about 1917 winning best
VFX sure yeah
they worked really hard on it I thought
it was an awesome movie too
ok so luckily for those of us using
After Effects and cinema 4d cinema 4d
and After Effects communicate really
well together so all you need to do and
this is this is pretty nuts all you need
to do is go to file export Maxon cinema
4d exporter and let's see it's it's
basically saying 2d layers will not be
found such as the footage hit OK and
let's save that let's save that where do
you want to save that does it matter of
course it matters guys because you gotta
stay organized
all righty so we open up c4d boom we're
in and how do we import it well you're
gonna go file open and you're going to
navigate to the folder that you just
saved that aftereffects export and
you're gonna open it and would you look
at this all right what's happening
what's happening let's it's all crazy
right now
so let's zoom out and see what the heck
is going on let's make a cube look okay
God our scale is off the charts guys
actually no not not as bad as I thought
but it's still off the charts if we look
at this camera hit shift f3 it'll bring
up your like tracking or your animation
window and see for D and we'll see we
got keyframes here for our camera and
that's a great sign that means cameras
should be moving but it's not moving why
is it not moving
why is our camera not moving let's zoom
in here see if it's moving or no okay
okay I know why okay it's because you
see we have frame zero right here and
we're going to frame you know one ninety
or so that's where the keyframes are
down here and our little a little
timeline we're at frame thirty three
hundred thirty eight thousand so that's
that's not chill let's go to our render
settings up here and let's set that
range from zero to one ninety right
because I think that's what we're
looking at and does that update this
down here no it does not
let's type it in manually zero to one
ninety and we'll stretch this out
and there you go wow that's a crazy
looking motion path okay yeah it's
because our it's because our um our
scale and everything is off but we're
gonna fix that we're gonna we're gonna
get that going okay so if I were to
select this plane here and cinema hold
down control and click the cube up here
we'll just spawn a little cube and you
know what for the sake of scale let's
spawn a dude instead so I'm holding down
control and letting go on figure our
axes are all off let's stand him up
hitting are holding down shift snapping
him to 90 degrees and the reason I use a
guy is because this this dude right here
this little mannequin is already 1.8
meters tall which is basically 5 9 it's
just a normal average human height here
so if we hop into our camera and we play
we can see it's moving right but that's
a real tiny person
so our skip we know our scale is off so
here's what we'll do let's save this
scene and it's saying it's an older
version sure saving it as the new
version let's bring in our footage into
cinema 4d because we're gonna need to
start referencing the footage so I'm
just going to double click down here and
we need to go back to After Effects solo
our footage layer and you can basically
what we're going to want to do is export
a JPEG sequence that we can import into
cinema 4d so I'm hitting ctrl shift I
believe that is /yeah the one the one
with the question mark on it
that brings it into the render queue and
I already have a little preset here for
JPEG sequence and I'm going to drop that
into a folder called tracking so let's
do that and save that so what that goes
how's everybody doing hopefully everyone
is good is everyone following along do
you guys have After Effects in c40 or
are you guys following along with like
blender and After Effects right now
alright Brisky asks how do you get big
on making VFX videos because I've been
trying to get noticed
I made an Instagram and everything and I
feel like I'm not going anywhere
totally totally that is something that
all of us have felt and I'd say first
off just make sure that what you're
doing you're passionate about and make
sure you do it consistently especially
if your start if you're trying to make
it like a business make sure you're
doing it because you're passionate about
it and because you actually enjoy what
you're doing and then that will be the
driver for doing it every day and you
know people if you guys don't know
people but look him up on Instagram it's
people underscore crap as his name and
he posts a new render using cinema 4d
and octane every single day and you know
how long he's been doing it for he's
been doing it for 11 years every single
day has not missed the day 11 years
despite having a job now this is his
full-time job now he travels the world
doing this but people didn't know about
people until like last year like 2 or 3
years ago so it took people like 9 years
to get to that level and the only reason
you know oh I can't say the only reason
but it's because he was passionate about
it that's what that's what drove him to
continue doing it
so Brisky I would say keep it just keep
it up make sure that you're you're
learning and you can't rush things you
cannot rush things all of us are very
used to getting what we want basically
as fast as possible we're very used to
immediate gratification with the
internet with Amazon with social media
everything we have is literally at our
fingertips right
but when you're trying to get good at
something it's not that easy
it takes a lot lot lot longer and more
reason for you to just be patient with
it
because let's say let's say you give up
right because not because it was hard
but because you know you were down about
it not being successful then what does
that mean for the future you know are
you going would you give up every time
you try something and it doesn't work
the first you know I don't know how long
you've been doing this I'm just using
this as a general example you know let's
say you give up on this you go to
another thing you give up on that you go
to another thing give up on that but
what if you were to just stick to the
first thing and you were to just you
know do it for years right eventually
it's gonna pop off like the Joe Rogan
podcast he said he was doing that for
ten years just cuz it was fun and he was
talking with his buddies about it or
talking with his buddies about you know
different stuff and it didn't pop off
until recently it's because he stuck
with it and there's actually if you guys
are down or interested in any sort of
books on this kind of stuff something
that I really really really loved and
that helped me a lot and explain this
idea of you get good at something right
and then you plateau and then most
people drop off and they give it up you
know you get super into golf you get all
the golf clubs you get a golf cart you
get a freakin a Club membership and you
sidon you're playing golf for like a few
months right and then all of a sudden
you're just like a golf you drop off
right I mean that's fine that's fine but
if you're really trying to get good at
golf it's not fine because you fell off
the map
you have to be okay with plateauing and
staying at this level and eventually
you're going to see a little bit of that
it might be a little bit but you're
gonna see a little bit of that right and
then eventually you're gonna plateau
again and then you might see a little
bit more and you're a plateau again for
a while maybe for a year and then you're
gonna see a little bit more and you're a
plateau and you're gonna keep rising and
rising and rising but it's gonna be slow
and it's gonna be over a long period of
time just know that that's normal that's
super okay and it is the only way to get
good at something is to stick to it and
be persistent so the book is called
mastery I'll pull it up for you and it's
a short read not the book by Robert
Greene or we know is it the book way
hold on there's two minute there's two
books called mastery just on Amazon here
two seconds
sorry guys mastery look ok yeah bye
George Leonard mastery by George Leonard
that's GE ou R GE le o ei na Rd George
Leonard mastery the keys of to success
and long-term fulfillment that's a good
one it is a really good one it can be
applied to literally everything so don't
get down
stick with it ok let's jump back in so
we're in cinema we have our JPEG
sequence exported let's open up that
material that we just made and for those
of you guys who are just joining we're
basically adding cool 3d stuff into
live-action footage right so we got the
shot and we want to add some cool stuff
to it right so we just tracked it in
after-effects now we're in cinema 4d and
we have our camera track here so how do
we make sure the camera track lines up
with the footage how do we check it
right that's what we're doing now so I'm
gonna double click down here in the
little materials window double click on
that and it's gonna be super simple
basically what you want to do is drag
your sorry I'm navigating to the folder
here you're gonna drag your folder that
has your jpg sequence in it you're gonna
drag that into the little texture bar
here totally didn't work let's try that
again you're gonna drag the first image
of your jpg sequence into that texture
bar right there and hit no and
automatically I believe it pulls it up
as a JPEG sequence but let's click this
image here and in this image you want to
make sure it's using all those frames so
up here in the animation tab you're
gonna calculate boom it just calculated
all your frames frame three and thirty
thousand two three hundred and thirty
thousand something something the reason
those numbers are so large is because in
After Effects if we go to composition
settings by hitting control K you can
see your start
is at 338,000 160 not chill usually
you'd set it to zero and that's that's
usually how it's gonna be if you ever
see this number and the far left as like
some astronomical number just go to
composition settings you can go to
composition and I believe it is
where's composition settings oh it's the
second option under composition control
K learn your shortcuts control K set
that start frame is zero and this number
should be at zero if it looks like this
then all I have to do is hold ctrl and
click it and it'll switch between frames
and timecode so that's why that number
is nuts we shot it at a frame rate of 24
so so far cinema 4d has done a great job
of doing you know a lot of the manual
work for us so what do we need to do
next we need to get that background
plate onto the background of our scene
so we'll do that by making a background
you can hold down this little floor
object here and let go on background
drag and drop that material that you
just made onto the background and oh my
good oh my goodness it's on the
background guys but it's not animating
why is it not animating dang it well
that's an easy fix
it's a super easy fix all you need to do
and by the way guys look at this you see
how these objects don't look like
they're stuck to the footage well I'm
getting ahead of ourselves let's make
sure the background is animated double
click the material the material you just
made go down to editor right down here
editor and check animate preview and
when you do that then and only then will
the background start catching up right
with you and it's a little choppy
alright that's just how it is so you
don't have to export full 4k JPEG
sequences
all you got to do is maybe like a you
know 720p or something it's gonna be
less taxing on your system and you know
what just for the sake of it I'm going
to do that so I'm gonna add it to render
queue again it's like JPEG sequence from
I'm gonna hit the little best settings
option and change it from quality best
where you see the size here I'm sorry
I'm gonna change the resolution from
full to quarter and you'll see we'll do
960 by 540 and I'll hit OK and we will
select the path it's going to and hit
render and that's gonna go give it a
second alright hopefully everyone's
falling we got 89 people in here this is
great doing awesome
ok so that just went I'm gonna update
this give me two shakes let's see
[Music]
alright
double click this and it should it
should just update there might be like a
refresh thing on here reload image let's
clear it let's just clear it entirely
and drop it on there again because doing
things twice is kind of the way to learn
these this stuff you do it once you're
gonna forget do it twice you might just
remember for the next time you do it see
there you go it goes from 0 to 186 not
338,000 and now look at that guys look
at that we can scrub now in our little
tiny guy is stuck to the footage that's
awesome let's get rid of the cube so our
little tiny dude is there that is
awesome it works
works flawlessly so let's um we still
need to orient this a little bit because
we're gonna light this thing right when
you want to light it with a Sun or an
HDR eye and if we go out of camera view
here by checking this little box I'm
gonna hide the background for a second
just so we can see what's going on I'll
go to filter and check the grid on and
you guys can see that the camera is
starting like just flat pointed straight
out to the horizon which is not the case
if we look at our footage we can
guesstimate that I am angled down at the
ground so that's how the camera should
start angled down at the ground and I'm
also not this keep in mind guys this
dude is two meters tall okay right so
that means there's probably like 40
meters between this object on the floor
and this camera right and that's
certainly not the case there's probably
three meters tops between me holding the
camera and this little sunspot so
getting your scale right in your 3d
program is a huge thing to get right
because light acts differently depending
on how big something is you're gonna get
more light bounces right it's just more
accurate you the more accurate you can
get this the better so let's solve this
problem here okay
alright the horizon we want to get our
horizon down so let's put some things
into a folder here the background can
stay out of our folder but let's put our
camera in a folder let's put this plane
in a folder and let's actually make a
plane that you know makes sense for how
big these things are so I'm gonna just
put this dude on a on an airplane on a
plane and this plane is 4 meters let's
see for me
by four meters I believe it's a really
cool tip here in in cinema that my buddy
Spencer told me about was if you type
one meter it will convert it for you if
you want it to be five inches it will
convert it for you so freaking cool blew
my mind
so let's say we want him on a 1 meter
tab by 1 meter little stand here our
dude is let's see is that right what
does that seem tiny if I make a cube
make a cube and say the cube is one
meter by one meter by one meter
yeah no that's that's right yeah it's
just shy of 2 meters so he's on a 1
meter
little box here 3 feet right by 3 feet
so we have him we have the plane and we
have the camera all in a null object
right here we'll just call this scene
yeah we'll call that scene and we're
going to rotate we're going to want to
rotate our scene until it matches a
reasonable size here so let's see if we
scale this down we hit T and scale it
down and then hit play it should see
yeah it should scale with the footage
here yeah all right so this guy we know
one thing right what do we know we know
that this guy needs to be on the ground
it needs to be flat on the ground so
let's see here we're going to want to
rotate this dude around right so we'll
go into our side view and we'll just get
it so that the plane is like flat on the
ground and the reason I'm not moving the
anchor point to the guy is because I
don't think it would work I had
something to do with the keyframes in
the camera it won't let you do it I
don't think so
yeah you see how it moves the camera
when I do that actually what is that
that big of a deal yeah you see it moved
the camera but yeah we can't do that
because as soon as you move the camera
it screws up the whole track so that's
why I'm not moving the anchor point and
rotating it around that guy it just has
to be done from from here unfortunately
so we're gonna zoom in and line it up so
that this is flat and he's on the ground
and you already you can see the camera
is coming at it from that higher angle
which is totally what we want so I'm
just gonna make sure he's flat from all
sides needs to be angled a little bit
more like this awesome
and here yeah that looks good
so it looks like he is now officially
standing on flat ground fantastic let's
see if we can get him on the origin so
I'm hitting W and that's switching
between local and world orientation and
we've talked about that a few times on
the last last couple streams and this is
very important right for this because we
want to just move this whole scene that
we have right together as one so let's
go up to our top view and we want to
move it so our dude is right at the
origin right there
okay check and he's a little tall so I'm
gonna move it down go to our side view
and make sure that he is sitting right
there boom right in the origin so when
we go to our camera view you know we're
right over top this dude and we'll
toggle our background back on and you
can see now you can see our grid is more
appropriate to our scene and we'll even
rotate it right so we'll rotate the
scene here so that our grid kind of
matches up with the flooring right and
everything then you want to try and get
these lines to go the right way and that
that makes sense to me right it's a
little off it's a little off you know
like you probably want to rotate it like
that so you can get your that feels
better
but you see once we did that and we go
out of camera view we hide our
background we come in here and you can
you'll see that a the dude is kind of
like rotated a little bit again so for
that I think what we'll do is let's see
probably just rotate them back but you
get you guys get the idea right you say
this is getting closer I'm just trying
to line up the grid with these wood
slats here
that feels right so now the only thing
that we have to get right is the scale
this guy is 2 meters tall so the scale
is astronomical right now if you select
your scene let's just start scaling this
thing down we hit T and we'll go to
local view I believe or a world but I
think what do we think what do we think
I'll hide the background yeah we'll go a
world view right or world orientation go
back into our camera turn on our
background and hopefully if we're doing
this right we should see this guy get
larger so let's see let's actually move
the plane and the figure outside of this
scene we just want to scale down the
camera so we'll hit T and we'll start
scaling and sure enough this guy is
getting bigger so I'm gonna scale this
down way down way down and let's see if
we can't move the figure back in place
in view of oh let's try that one more
time scaling it down okay for some
reason so let me scale when I scale it
from the viewport like this and I hit
play it snaps back to the original
position one way to get one way to get
around that is go to your scene and you
actually have to type in the scale here
so let's let's take it from let's just
make it a tenth of the size so point one
point one point one and now when you hit
play yeah it it stays so let's see if we
got that right let's move this figure
back in place
and how do we know when he's on the
ground right cuz he could be floating at
any certain point here so let's see
let's go out of our camera view and
let's put him actually on the ground and
this is kind of you guys can see how
this is kind of like a give and take
situation where everything moves
together so we'll put the dude back in
the folder with the camera and we'll
move this back up to the ground level
here right so right about there and
we'll go back in the camera view and now
okay so now you can see he's a little
bit he's a he's a lot bit taller
actually but our camera track is off why
is our camera track off things are
slipping now you guys see that
see how things are slippin and slidin
that's no good so let's try setting this
back to 1 and things are still slippin
and slidin what happened hmm
problem solving this is the best part of
VFX I'm gonna need to bust out the chips
and the hummus for this one Oh what up
see Mike dude see Mike's up in here
everyone say hello to Carmichael
Carmichael man hope you're doing well I
guess see Mike left he's touring a 400
year old coffee farm very cool
all right so someone's got a Japanese
name in the chat here currently I'm
learning Japanese so this is very
exciting for me looks like it says da
Donna I don't know something maybe
that's not now I'm learning my katakana
my hiragana you know I'm working at it
it's like one of my favorite countries
ever all right
let's hop back in guys
you know what let me get some music
going here just for me though cuz I
can't monetize these things without the
music let's see um what do you want to
jam out to today I'm gonna do that
ambient playlist most of you guys know I
got that ambient from VFX playlist it's
in the description of this video here
little Spotify action for you guys
[Music]
sweet all right we're in what's up Jason
my days been well I woke up I ran two
miles guys I'm training for a half
marathon right now I'm very excited for
that but yeah I got my run in and I'm
doing VFX guys we're trying to solve
this problem why why is our track off
now look at our track it's slipping and
sliding all over the place what happened
guys we had it we had it when in doubt
undo a few times y'all when in doubt
just undo a few times let's go back
maybe it's sliding here too
I think it is I think it's actually
sliding yeah okay so maybe this is
something in after-effects where we need
to normalize our scene and man Ren is so
good at this I need this is when you
need Ren on the stream to help out and
Natalie what's up Natalie how's it going
man everyone's joining in this is
awesome
thank you guys I really appreciate you
guys manually we're trying to
troubleshoot a little 3d track situation
here so it's looking pretty good here in
after-effects but as soon as I bring it
in a C for D it appears to be working
but I think there's some slippin and or
sliding going on here with the track so
I could cheat I could cheat you know and
just track this in cinema 4d and it's
like the easiest thing ever
it's extra easy and I might do that you
know I might just do that but let's just
give this another 5 minutes and if we
can't figure it out in five minutes
we'll track it and see 4d so here's what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do the surefire
method here I'm going to add those on
sharp masks to this footage okay
and we're gonna get this thing nice and
contrast II so there's a lot of detail
to track here
okay I'm gonna pre-comp this control
shift see and move all attributes into
the new composition great I'm going to
add the 3d camera tracker I'm gonna tell
it it's a variable zoom because we are
zooming in I'm gonna check that Advanced
tab the detailed analysis tab because
you know why not and we are going to say
this is a mostly flat scene that's what
we'll say it's a mostly flat scene so
we're gonna give it as much info as
possible and uh Sharif or sheriff sweet
name
you actually there's a little bit of a
framerate you bring up frame rate okay
so this frame rate here is 23 976 and
I'm looking at that through the
composition settings hit control K to
bring that up 23 9 9 7 6
now unfortunately cinema 4d doesn't do
29 or 23 976 it only does 24 so if you
control D you can see your project
settings and your FPS is sure enough 24
and if I try and hit 23 976 it will not
do that it'll just go to 23 usually in
the past that has not been an issue for
me but let's let's give this another
shot here it's going along here we got 2
more minutes on this thing
okay Tyler man asks what's the glove you
wear and what's the green thing on my
ears so the glove which I don't have on
right now but the glove allows me to
glide across my tablet here easily right
so I use a Wacom tablet and the glove
allows me to like you know very easily
slide across the surface of this thing
you know if I'm sweaty for whatever
reason it's gonna stick and be gross
it just keeps your natural oils off of
this thing all right so it's easier to
navigate that's what the gloves for I
currently at the moment cannot find it
it's probably in a pant pocket somewhere
and the green things around my ears
these are bone phones or that's what I
call them but they're tricks
err bone conduction headphones and
they're the coolest things ever because
you put them over your ear like so and
they don't go in your ear like that they
go just right outside so you can still
hear but you also have awesome music
going at the same time and I use that
when I run I'll use that when I walk go
on hikes I'll use it at work I'll use it
on set I'll use it I have them all the
time
and it's a way to just kind of add a
little soundtrack to your life you know
so these are like basically the greatest
things ever I love him so so much
I need the questions you guys MC j for w
ry i don't know i don't know how to
pronounce that name
he asks or she asks have any of you at
corridor ever touched nuke for
compositing we have not I really want to
very bad very badly it is very expensive
though so not yet that expensive touch
yes the glove is broken on training that
is true dude
Pablo the sound quality is super nice on
these things and I actually just came
out with another model
that are even better believe it or not
they're even better it's crazy alright
so the camera is solving we have a track
here hopefully yep I'm going to select
the little areas these little four
points right click we're gonna add solid
down delete the old stuff so that's our
solid we're gonna rotate it a little bit
and I want to figure out a way in
after-effects to zero out the scene so
if I create a new solid and make it 3d I
want it to be able to just appear in the
middle which it actually looks like it
does you know it's something that is
zero zero zero whereas here the position
is it's off right it's some it's some
other numbers and I know there's a
tutorial out there somewhere on how to
do that
I just don't we don't have the time
right now but okay we have our we have
our solid here right and I'm just gonna
go ahead and say let's move forward with
this I'm not even gonna test it so let's
um let's export this file export Maxon
cinema4d exporter okay I'll call this
camera track two will go into C 40 will
make a new scene we'll open that and
there we go we got our camera track
let's see if we can't just flatten this
out so we want to rotate this scene
right
so that this ground plane is actually
the ground plane
something like that
and then we'll just drop it down on the
ground right about there we'll add a
dude and okay it looks normal but you
know it really comes down to this where
we throw in our background here so I'll
drop that in I'll hit no I'll come in
here I'll go to the animation tab
calculate that go to editor check
animate preview and this is the third
time we're doing this so we're learning
even more or in graining all this stuff
we're gonna make a background let's do
that
click little floor tab at the background
drop your material onto there and let's
hide the plane for a second and let's
just see if this is working it looks to
be working yes it looks to be working
sweet okay
now the scale is still off right so how
do we solve that hopefully we should
just start scaling this thing down and
it would work let us hide the background
again and
let's see let's scale everything scale
the scene down ok so that doesn't work
let's type the numbers in manually
all right and then let's just move this
thing back into place here
all right
there you go guys I think it works so
the unsharp mask helped with the track a
little bit more give it more stuff track
I think it made it a bit more accurate
we got this model standing in here I
think it's a little big so I'm just
gonna take our scene and bring it back
up to 0.1 I think that's a bit more
accurate and I'm going to just Center
that up for the last time and we'll move
on we will move on
is everybody following along this is
make sense to everybody
dude what the heck what the heck it's
sliding again why why is it sliding oh
man why y'all this is this is this is it
man this is this is VFX for ya
this is VFX for you guys problem solving
I'm gonna say screw it for this because
this is tract and it's close enough all
you just we just need to adjust our
scale by a little bit so let's let's
move on so let's um let's start with
something really really basic let's
start with just like a sphere okay we'll
start with the sphere and we'll scale it
down and we'll have it sit on the floor
alright so let's see if the spheres
radius is 20 centimeters that means if
it's centered right there it needs to
move up by 10 centimeters sorry 20
centimeters and now it'll be sitting on
the floor let's hide this person and
let's scrub forward and there is a ball
sitting right there I'm gonna actually
bring the radius of this thing down a
little bit will make it more of like a
soccer ball size so let's try 10
centimeters 12 centimeters and that
means it needs to just come up by 12
centimeters so it's sitting on the
ground and there you go there you have
like a basketball on the ground right
over these two light strips and that
that's great because we'll comp in the
light strips and we'll add the light to
our scene
so um let's do something let's uh let's
take the segment's up 200 so the sphere
is nice and round and we will render our
scene here and this looks nothing like
this ball sitting on this ground here so
what we need to do what we need to do a
couple things first off remember how in
the last stream we talked about path
tracing versus direct lighting okay in
this case we're gonna want path tracing
because you want these you want the
light to come in through these windows
and bounce around and give you the most
realistic looking sphere you can
possibly imagine right so let's let's
change it to path tracing and we're
gonna want to essentially say we want to
render this out with a transparent
background so to do that you're gonna
want to go to your render settings up
here and I totally lied you're gonna go
to your octane settings because that's
what we're using to render is octane
today we'll go to octane settings and
we'll scroll down just a little bit and
we will check alpha channel and you can
see already we're seeing our background
and if you you're gonna also want to
check keep environment so there you go
you can see this gray blob sitting on
top of the floor here now instead of a
gray blob let's get something a lot
cooler let's go to mega scans dot se oh
this is awesome and what a great website
they actually oh my god guys I think
they updated their website oh my god
guys they updated their website oh okay
guys this is my favorite website of all
time oh oh man so many assets so many
cool things do we want to do a carat did
we just wanted to like pile of carrots
on the ground turnips and carrots just
piles of turnips when turnips and
carrots or do we want to do like
I don't know pairs we can do gourds we
do carrots and gourds what do you guys
think we could do carrots gourds and
pomegranates we can put an urn on the
ground we can put up bucket an old an
old wooden bucket on the ground I don't
think it matters really I think it
matters too much I could just spend
hours on this website guys Oh an old
wooden chest a cat see now we could do a
cat but that would just take a little
bit more time than we all have here
today um a wooden barrel now that's a
little tall for the camera angle we have
cabbage any cabbage let's do a cabbage
search cabbage yo we got cabbage
trending assets yo this cabbage this
cabbage is trending right here we can do
the trending cabbage if you guys are
down for that anything else a Buddha is
Buddha booty an option do I spell that
right
[Music]
sorry there's no Buddha reflective
aspects ok reflective aspects would
totally be sweet if we had an awesome
HDRI image of my house which I do not
have I'm sure we could fake it a little
bit um you know what guys we're doing
carrots carrots and cabbage one let's
let's get this log in on the other
screen so y'all don't steal my password
that'd be that not be good at all okay
carrot downloading carrot guys this is
wonderful I'm so amped
okay okay I'm so I am for this um let's
see let's see let's save this to the
right place cuz you gotta save it to the
right place
veggies vegetables um be organized guys
be organized carrot boom got it what
else cabbage cabbage will do cabbage -
yes yes carrot cabbage boom okay so I'm
gonna unpack these right and build out
these assets real quick for you guys
this is the best part guys we got the
camera track done we're gonna get the
lighting nice and then we're gonna add
in these carrots and cabbage oh it's
gonna be so nice it can be so nice okay
new scene it's cabbage time oh it's
cabbage time guys I lied it's carrot
time guys
look at that that's a carrot right there
I carry it um okay let's build this
thing out I'm gonna make a glossy
material put it on our carrot I'm also
going to make a little HDRI scene so
that we can you know really just respect
this carrot you know treat it right it
needs to be treated right you know what
am i saying I don't know what I'm saying
it needs to be lit properly that's what
I'm saying let's go in here
and let's start building out dis current
so we have our normal map our roughness
map we have our ambient occlusion and we
have our color map so we're gonna drop
all those into octane we're gonna save
our scene guys please save your work my
goodness save your work guys
and let's see let's see our normal map
watched you guys watch this carrot
transform watch this carrot transform
look at the defuse okay that looks like
something normal map you see how the
ridges got all up in there but it's like
still super glossy and weird-looking so
you're gonna add that roughness to it
dude that's a carrot look at that carrot
that's nice for the sake of this will do
will do one more carrot here cuz this
pack comes is it weird that I can taste
carrots I lied that it comes with one
carrot guys it's just the one alright
I'm sorry I got your hopes up let's
let's get our cabbage going see what the
cabbage looks like so will reading that
rename that to carrot let's drop in our
cabbage make sure you save your scene
I'm on a roll now glossy material boom
drag-and-drop render to the scene oh
let's take our HDRI sky from our carrot
and we'll put it on the cabbage render
that path tracing looking nice let's hop
in here and what do we want our
roughness are normal are in our color
those three as all we need so take a
roughness drop that in there take our
note or a normal map drop it in there
and our color boom right in there so now
we got our cabbage guys we got a carrot
so let's drop them in the scene real
quick I'm gonna show you guys a really
cool trip trip what am I saying I'm
going to show you guys a really cool
trick and it's the fastest way to get a
pile of cabbage and carrots go
hopefully you guys are all good everyone
go in the chat thumbs ups all around
everyone's still in on this okay so I'm
copying our cabbage we're going to tab
over to camera track - this is the scene
we're doing boom paste
there's the cabbage let's grab the
carrot because we're trying to eat
healthy these days camera track - boom
paste the carrot we got a carrot look at
that and it's kind of to scale - that's
the best part so let's do something
soups awesome right now okay let's do
something freakin sick right now here's
what I want to do I want a pie just a
pile of cabbage and carrots in the
middle of the ground right here right
now how do we do that well you can place
them manually like a freaking loser or
we can do it with physics so let's do it
with physics let's get out of the camera
and for whatever reason guys if you
start moving the camera around here and
it messes up your say actually it snaps
right back that's beautiful okay no
worries just make sure you're out of
camera view hide your background because
it's not chill to look at when you're
just you know trying to enjoy yourself
in 3d and then also let's take the
camera and toggle the first little
circle up here hit that once turns green
hit it twice turns red and that hides it
in the viewer so now we're just looking
at the stuff we need to be looking at
cleaning up the scene a little bit right
so let's render this alright and we'll
get the lighting in a second but let's
build this pile of carrots and cabbage
so I'm a pause that we don't need GPU
okay here's how we do this we're going
to go to mograph cloner right so now we
have a cloner we're gonna drop our
carrot
and our cabbage into that cloner all
right you can see how it's already
starting to clone stuff go to the cloner
and under mode change that to grid array
now we have a grid of carrots and
cabbage this is fantastic so what we're
gonna want to do here is basically just
drop a whole bunch of carrots and
cabbage down into a pile and we'll do
that by you know what let's go let's go
honeycomb array just just cuz all right
and it's way spread out so we need to
bring our width down to like I don't
know 50 centimeters 20 centimeters 15
centimeters and our height will be the
same 15 centimeters so we have a wall of
carrots and cabbage let's actually
switch this back to grid array okay and
let's just change everything to 15 15 15
we have this ball here let's go out 20
20 20 try 40 40 40 we don't want
anything touching okay cuz that's gonna
really mess up the physics simulation
and just for clarity we have a ground
here okay and that's the ground we're
gonna be dropping it on too so let's
take our cloner and move it up
alright cuz we want the stuff to fall
into place okay everything looks way too
uniform so what we're gonna do is with
your cloner selected go to mograph
effector and use a random effector and
the random effector is my favorite we
talked about it on the modeling stream
right when we were building that tank
and adding the little little beams we
wanted them to be a bit have a bit of
randomness to them for this we're gonna
uncheck position I think rotation is
gonna be the main deal so we'll go 360
all around and I'm just tabbing down and
that is looking sweet okay we can do
position to 10 by 10 so things are
moving around a little bit again we just
want to be very careful that nothing is
touching okay and you can see how this
is inside of that when we when we hit
the the physics simulation this is gonna
just bowl
up we don't want that okay so let's go
five five five and it looks like
everything is separate and not touching
which is totally what we want so if you
want more of a carrot - cabbage ratio
all you need to do is go into your
cloner here and we have two things right
in the cloner we have a carrot and we
have a cabbage and it is splitting it up
50/50 so there's the exact amount of
cabbages for the exact amount of carrots
now if you copy and paste the carrot and
drop it into the cloner it's gonna give
you basically for every one cabbage
you'll get two carrots just like this
and I wish there was a way to randomize
the order of this and I bet there is but
I let's see it might be like a step
modifier or something it might be some
other modifier - to randomize like how
these things are placed in here maybe
it's
[Music]
hmm I bet you there's a way clones
random Oh is it that's probably it
instead of iterate yeah it's just set to
random let's add another cabbage and
then like one more carrot that feels
right so we this is a ball of veggies
we're gonna drop on the floor here so
let's save our scene guys let's save
this thing and you guys are awesome all
right we're in we're in okay let's drop
this thing so the cloner right it needs
it needs something we need to we need to
toggle gravity we need to toggle physics
here if I hit play nothing's happening
that's okay so if you select a cloner
right click it and go down to simulation
tags now these simulation tags that's
what is going to simulate your physics
these things dropping at bouncing on the
floor if you go to give it a rigid body
tag and that's really all you're gonna
need for this thing so the cloner has a
rigid body tag let's hit play and see
what happens nothing okay actually
something it fell it fell but it fell
through the ground and totally isn't
what we're going for so what do we need
to do well okay we have this floor let's
actually make it a plane okay we'll make
a plane and plane let's say play again
same deal right same deal the simulation
right it needs to know what's in play
here you have things falling onto what
you have things falling onto a ground
and it's not recognizing the plane
because it needs a tag just like our
vegetables have a has a have a rigid
body tag the
plane also needs a Collider body and the
collider is basically saying whatever
has the collider body tag it knows okay
anything with rigid body or soft body
physics it's gonna bounce off of the
collider bodies okay so at play and hope
you know that that's kind of working
right but not really like if they were
glued together with invisible toothpicks
this would be it this would be the vibe
right but totally not the vibe it's it's
basically the rigid body is just on the
cloner but the cloner has all these
other objects inside so how do we say a
rigid body tag look at all the things
inside of the cloner and that's very
simple I have to do is select the rigid
body tag and c40 and we'll go to
collision and the inherent tag and the
individual elements that's what we want
okay
so individual elements let's just set it
to all and see what happens
it worked but like there's they're
they're bouncing all crazy and Stern
around all weird so we need to fix that
okay how we gonna do that
inherent tag let's go ahead and tag
let's let's actually try a little test
you know let's turn individual elements
to off inherent tag we'll set to apply
tag to children which basically means
we're gonna apply the rigid body tag to
the children of the object that the
rigid body tag is applied to in this
case the carrots and cabbage and all
that stuff so that's not working
apply tag to children let's try it
compound collision shapes what does that
do
same deal okay so we're gonna apply tag
to the children and we're gonna set it
to top-level okay that's that's working
that's basically I think as far as gonna
get with this so I think what we're
gonna do here let's see is I think it's
a physics issue right
things are bouncing all over the place
and like they're kind of jittery on the
floor here so what I'd do to solve that
is let's give these things zero bounce
in a hundred friction which means
they're basically gonna stick to
whatever they hit okay but we're still
having some some movement after the fact
here so I think now what we need to do
is up the iterations in c40 so I'm gonna
hit control D and we're gonna go to
dynamics the dynamics tab and we'll go
to expert and it's basically saying okay
we have five we have five checks per
frame every frame that goes by there's
like five instances where the gravity
and the collisions are being checked
let's up that to 15 and see if a more
more of like an eagle-eye check instead
of five times we're on fifteen checks to
make sure things are nice and clean
let's see what that does way better way
better way better okay way better that's
it guys
that's that's really it we can go
another level on this thing let's
duplicate let's take our cloner okay
let's stack it instead of count 3 on the
Y let's go count six and let's open it
up a little bit move it up a little bit
and hit play again and now we have even
more on the floor here I think that's
great so we'll go into our camera and
we'll hide our plane and we really we
want to see if any of these carrots or
cabbages like going through the wall or
something right so let's just like huh
that's that's great we have carrots and
cabbage down here
it's looking awesome but we have this
one carrot this one cabbage that's going
through the wall which isn't chill we
definitely don't want that um Casey
thank you I appreciate you man
thanks for stopping by I'm glad that
this is helping you guys out I really do
thank you so much thank you so much glad
we're all learning together spending
time on our craft here and having a good
time
um let's see
David but the effects can be achieved
with other tools just got a problem
solve yes problem solved that's really
what it is decent amount of motion
graphics tools are not available in
After Effects cinema 4d Lite yeah so
After Effects does come with C 40 light
which is pretty sweet I've never used it
to be honest um but yeah I mean we just
got a you know problem solve and figure
out other cool creative ways of doing so
but let's let's do a thing here but we
actually need to build out the geometry
of our scene because if we're having
physics happen here we have a wall right
here right so we want to put that wall
in because some of these carrots and
cabbage might be hitting the wall and
rolling up against the wall so how do we
do that well let's get out of camera
view real quick and let's create a cube
move it over and let's go back into
camera view and let's actually just see
where this cube is landing here I'm
gonna line it up with the carpet go to
local orientation and it looks like
let's see we'll bring the cube in and we
know that the floor is colliding with
the ground so we'll bring this cube up
I'm gonna make it editable by hitting C
I'm going to drop the anchor point to
the bottom so we can have better control
over this thing and I'm just putting it
right on the ground there and hopefully
if I move this back to the corner of the
wall it looks a little far to be honest
though yeah we want we want it to be
lined up we want this cube to be lined
up with the corner of that wall so
where's our plane well just for the sake
of visual for a visual check let's make
this thing like a light green here and
then we'll make the wall the wall can be
white and let's make these things
see-through so we can see where they're
lining up if I select both the cube and
the plane and hit x-ray you should be
able to see through these things and
let's turn on let's actually turn off
the renderer let's turn on the
background in our viewport and just see
if like I'm going to turn off the cloner
in the viewport as well let's turn a
figure back on so we can see the feet
and we basically want this corner to
line up here with this wall and that's
basically the only objects we need to
add into the scene here because this
wall is actually gonna help it's gonna
like bounce the the cabbage and the
carrots are gonna bounce off of that and
actually that looks pretty great I just
moved it up and it's lined up pretty
nicely right there and the wall is gonna
be white so I'll make this cube white as
well so let's turn the renderer back on
and
let's turn off x-ray mode right so we
have our like a room here will turn the
figure off and we'll add the cloner back
on and here's what you're gonna want to
do here let's run the sim again and we
have this wall in place okay I'm gonna
turn off the octane view let's hit play
and see what happens they're hitting the
ground but the cabbage is rolling
through the wall so what we're gonna
want to do is give the wall a Collider
body as well so I'm going to control
drag the collider tag from the plane
onto the wall so now the wall is in play
things are bumping up against the wall
so i'ma hit pause on this okay
go into our camera view let's go real
quick let's uh it's the best way to do
this you know let's just let's just say
screw it let's go to the cloner the
rigid body tag and we're gonna freeze
the position of these the cabbage and
the carrots here okay that's the whole
reason we're doing the dynamics here is
to just freeze them and get a
natural-looking spill on the ground so
what I'll do is in the rigid body tag
we'll go to cache no we'll go to
dynamics and we'll hit set initial state
so when you go to frame zero that's the
initial starting state and then
hopefully if we what's the best way to
do this if we delete the rigid body tag
boom okay that's not our answer if we go
to cache and we bake the object it's
going to essentially bake the simulation
okay and then if we delete the tag then
no that doesn't work okay basically I'm
just trying to get this shape okay so
maybe what we need to do is select the
cloner and select all the objects inside
right-click
go to connect objects and that that work
no that didn't really work huh okay
let's see we know that this first frame
is our initial state frame one okay why
did that not work well it's because it's
baked let's clear all caches go to frame
1 setting the initial state when we hit
play they're just kind of chilling there
on the ground and I just I just want
them to be still here so hmm well at the
end of the day we're gonna to render
this out regardless right we should
probably get rendering pretty soon all
right let's hop into our camera view
let's render our scene and instead of
these walls right here let's have it
just be our footage so what we need to
do is make them shadow catchers so
basically you're making the ground in
the wall transparent so we will make a
new material a diffuse material okay
you're gonna drag and drop that onto the
floor onto the wall double-click that
and let's see here we'll go to common
and we'll check the shadow capture box
and there you can see these vegetables
and these carrots and the cabbage are in
the scene with shadows and everything
looking pretty nice but they don't look
realistic that's because the lighting is
not right we need to nail the lighting
here
so how are we gonna do that guys it's
gonna be easy I promise okay
so basically we need to build out the
house very quickly and light it with
like a sunlight okay so we're gonna hop
out of camera view zoom out here and
let's take our plane here and since I
know what my house looks like basically
gonna stretch this floor out this wall
becomes a wall over here I'm gonna
duplicate it again holding ctrl and
holding shift I'm gonna make this back
wall here okay it's probably around
there is where the refrigerator is and
there's another wall back here and then
I'll make a cube and bring this in like
this okay that is very important we do
this okay we're gonna duplicate that
again and we're gonna make my monitor
technically there's two monitors like
this and technically it's kind of like
it's kind of like that and then I am
streaming from this position like so and
but just imagine I'm in a chair okay so
that's where I am streaming right now
and this is where the footage was shot
like back over here okay
and there's a window here you know
there's actually a few windows so I'm
looking at the house here and I'm seeing
there's a window one two three and
there's some windows all around right so
let's uh let's make these windows real
quick with a boo-boo lien or a or a bool
object okay so I'm just roughing this in
and this is really gonna help like the
more accurate you get this the better
and this is where you know maybe
measurements and dimensions come into
play right because it's the most
accurate version when it's the most you
know closest to real life window size
right it's gonna match it perfectly
so I'm just guesstimating this guy's
probably getting a window about about
yay up here I'm gonna get these walls
right okay the walls are gonna make a
bit more sense here let's see the window
is about probably there we have another
window which is at the front door
something like this and this all of this
whole process is to get the lighting
right okay we have another window in the
corner about like that on the other side
of the room we have a door like this and
you don't have to you don't have to
model this stuff like exactly right you
don't have to add your bevels and all
this and we got another window here a
small one like this next to that we have
a little bit larger and then on the
other side we have a window like that
that's that window right behind me yeah
is this window right here
as you can see by this perfect
reenactment
that we have set up here okay so that's
about that it needs a roof okay because
it technically is an interior scene so
let's take these cubes one two three
four and group them together and we want
to put them in a bool modifier here a
little object and let's take all these
cubes all these windows we made one two
three four five six seven windows will
group those windows together and
basically we're gonna say our room which
is a- our windows which are be alright
and we'll say it's one object create
single object hide new edges and our
let's see our our windows aren't thick
enough so i just need to come through
all these little windows here and just
kind of open them up a little bit so
that they're punching through the entire
wall
so this is going to be on just 3d
tracking and dropping in objects this is
making them look realistic because
that's the biggest thing you can add
your sphere you can add whatever to your
scene but it's not gonna look realistic
unless you light it properly I'm gonna
continue and make sure the floor is
correct I'm gonna take these walls these
walls I'm gonna move up because
technically the roof goes up the ceiling
goes up there and I have a like arched
kind of like an arched ceiling but for
the sake of this tutorial I'm not gonna
do that I'm gonna just put a cube come
on
I'm just gonna put a cube as the ceiling
here a little topper cover this up
all right and it also needs the same
shadow catcher no I lied doesn't need
the shadow catcher but what we do need
is we need to color these walls the
right color because it's actually
reflecting you want the cabbage and
everything to be reflecting the right
stuff so let's continue we need to let's
light this thing first all right so it's
very dim right now because the scene
isn't really being lit so I'm gonna pop
out of there and let's hide some walls
here so we can see what's going on see
here
boom and we'll hide the ceiling and I'm
just gonna renaming this stuff so I know
what's going on
okay this wall I know this wall right
here needs to scoot over because the
sunlight is coming through that window
and we don't want to block it
where the heck there it is
all right so the Morning Sun is coming
through about this angle so let's make a
Sun octane sunlight and well basically
where this line is the Sun is pointing
in that direction so the Sun is shooting
straight up through the ground we want
it to go the other way so it's noon I'm
gonna better position the roof here yep
okay so let's better position the Sun
let's hide our background so we can see
what we're doing
we'll take the floor and move it across
this way um where's the Sun here we go
here we go yeah so the Sun is kind of
shining through these windows here okay
it looks really ugly definitely not the
vibe we're going for here
so maybe instead of okay why is this the
Sun is coming through like there's no
walls then I think it's because of our
shadow catcher we have things that our
shadow catchers that should not be
shadow catchers so let me see what it
looks like if we take the shadow catcher
off I'm gonna come out of camera view
here slide into our scene hide the grid
for seconds I'm gonna see what we're
doing and the Sun should be shining
through these windows right here down
onto our cabbage so we just need to get
the lighting the angle correct there we
go okay so there's those two beams of
light that we're looking for maybe we
can move our windows down a little bit
and angle the Sun down a bit
right just trying to get those light
streaks to look to be in there
and let's add an HDR eye to the
environment so it's dark it's very dark
that's the first thing I'm noticing is
extremely dark so we were closer in the
beginning right so maybe what I'll do is
take off the ceiling here just take a
look at our footage
it's pretty evenly lit everyone's still
following yeah everyone's still good I
feel like I'm losing a little energy
hopefully we're everyone still hanging
in there snack break
yeah thunderous the bath house was the
bath house from spirited away in the
first stream
okay Johnny has a good point he says the
light bounces will be stronger and more
bright when the walls are actually white
and have something you know light to
bounce around Alejandra I'm doing pretty
good man
I'm enjoying some hummus and pretzels
right now
let's um let's start wrapping this thing
up so we want we want white walls for
everything here I think it's gonna help
bounce all of the light a bit more so
let's make a new diffuse white diffuse
material
oops I totally deleted our cabbage
texture and everything
what happened to our what what happened
our carrot texture
all right there we go okay so the floor
is like a wood color so what we'll do is
reference that let's bring up our
background and hide the ground plane
here and we will reference with this
little eyedropper the wood color and
that's a reflective material so we'll
change it from diffuse to glossy and
we'll add the roughness we'll crank the
roughness up because that's a very rough
reflection so we'll make sure that's on
the ground okay
next we will add a bit of color to our
walls so let's bring those guys back in
still very very very dark I'm gonna mess
with some octane settings here okay all
right let's make a diffuse material and
we're just gonna max out the brightness
on this thing so we'll set the diffusion
instead of point nine we'll go to one
and we will drop that on the bull object
because that's you know that's
everything that's all the walls and it's
not looking bright I'm gonna take the
ceiling off
that helps a lot that helps that helps a
whole lot yeah I took the ceiling off
that that works it feels that feels
better so let's go back to camera view
see what we're looking at and let's make
sure the floor and the wall okay those
both of those materials we made let's
make sure those are both shadow catchers
because at the end of the day we want we
want the the background to be completely
removed so we can drop this render into
After Effects so if you select both of
these what's really cool about cinema is
if you select multiple things you can
change settings across the board with
just one click so with both of those
materials selected I'm gonna go to
editor and now I'm sorry common and
actually wait okay here's the thing this
is why it's not an option the shadow
catcher option is only available for
diffuse materials right so if you go to
common turn shadow catcher on it's gonna
work for the wall okay but that poses
another problem because now the sunlight
is coming through it's not the wall
isn't blocking our our render so let's
turn that off and instead of turning it
to a shadow catcher what we can do is
turn it off in the renderer within
octane okay so if you go to your floor
right here your ground you right-click
and you go to c4d octane tags give it an
octane object tag and if you go to
visibility you can turn off camera
visibility right so that means you're
not gonna be able to see the floor
through the camera but now we've lost
our shadows so we have to figure this
one out
let's see
let's go to our floor and instead of
having a being a reflective material
let's go to basic and change it back to
diffuse and let's try just turning that
to a shadow catcher and see what happens
okay it's very dark very very dark hmm
what if we take the ground and we turn
the visibility off that gets rid of our
shadows so maybe what we need to do is
render our shadow pass separate from
this pass right here and that might end
up being the option here so let's take
our wall let's take our wall which is
the white material and let's set that to
shadow catcher that doesn't work because
it takes it away the sun is shining
through it we don't want that let's
apply the same octane tag to our wall so
that would be there so now we have you
know these vegetables more properly lit
for the scene or in here and I think the
vegetables are a bit more contrast II
than the footage and we can deal with
that certainly in in After Effects but
if you want to do it in octane you can
basically if you excuse me for your
camera if you give your camera an octane
tag an octane camera tag you have a
whole bunch of cool options so under
camera imager if you enable that you can
set your color space here from RGB to
linear and set your gamma at a 2.2 you
can keep cranking that and it's going to
flatten things out a bit and make it you
know feel like it's more in the space
here we're basically doing a little bit
of
positing in a inside of octane the
saturation is a little high I think we
can go like point nine on the saturation
and the only thing we're missing here
guys is the the shadow pass which we'll
just have to kinda I think we'll have to
do separate now let's see if we can get
this hot there's a highlight here right
if I hide the cloner let's see in the
footage you can see this like hot
highlight I want to see if we can't get
that going in the render because that's
gonna add a lot of realism to to the
scene so I'm basically going to start
moving my windows around until that
those highlights become apparent so
let's see here where's my son
hmm
let's see let's see let's maybe see
where they're at on the floor so if we
go to the ground and we turn camera
visibility back on it looks like the
sunlight needs to be shining a bit more
angled down more like that will turn the
ground visibility back off oh now it's
shining for the roof that's not what we
want we don't want to do that these
windows these windows should be
registering maybe it's so we're trying
to get a sunlight to come through the
windows there we go
maybe I'll just open up this window a
bit more in the back here
ingesting the sunlight
and the window I'm just like you know
pushing and pulling this so that let me
get that streak of sunlight right on the
cabbage there there we go okay so now
you can see it there
it's coming through it's very very close
we're very close
perfect now we have this little like
sunlight spot right right in there all
right so now let's see we can't line it
up with the actual footage and we're
gonna need to see through the floor so
we'll turn the ground we'll turn the
camera visibility visibility back off
and it'll zoom in here
oh thank you so much what is this you
don't know they give you the wrong drink
oh that's good thank you yeah I think
area lights on windows would probably
probably work but for the sake of this
thing we're gonna keep moving so you can
see that sunlight streak is right there
we want to line it up more so with this
piece here so we'll do that by rotating
the Sun that's so hard to see
we're so close guys like that you can
see it right there
so I'll scoot the window over a bit more
open it up a bit
there's probably an easier way of doing
this I'm gonna rotate the Sun and move
the window again that's basically it
yeah
and then let's see how that see how
bright that is that streak so I think
what I'm gonna do is just take the
sunlight settings and take the power to
like two and then let's see if we go
let's go actually power back to one and
then if we go to our octane camera
settings you can go to post-processing
enable that and we can turn on like the
bloom and I think that's gonna help a
lot so let's just crank that to like ten
let's get rid of our wall here okay
glare power like five I'm just gonna
crank this to the max we'll go like 100
and glare blur we'll set that to one
glare amount we'll go five glare power
fifty and you can really see how like
it's like a hot spot right on the Sun
piece there and if you turn it on and
off you can kind of see how it's being
affected and we can really mess with
this in After Effects that's gonna help
a lot
so I think it's like about time we
started rendering this thing last little
thing I'm gonna do here is bring this
window crunch this window down so that
the glare isn't going beyond the glare
in the actual footage yeah there you go
so you have it on those like cabbage
pieces but not on this carrot let's
render this so we can render our shadow
pass this piece of cabbage back here
we're gonna want to delete that and
we'll go to the beginning of our footage
here for the sake of roto we can delete
that as well but I think we'll just do
that in After Effects we'll mask that
stuff out in after-effects let me set up
this render here so what we won't do for
can't render because we don't have time
let's do 1280 by 720 and framerate 23
976 yep all frames sounds good let's go
to octane settings samples 300 which is
a very low sample rate but again for the
sake of the tutorial we will keep moving
I'm gonna turn on my a ID noise er and
you'll see that in the camera imager tab
here basically you'll be able to pump
out renders quickly with low low samples
if you turn on your AI dee' noise er and
you can see that right here spectral AI
D noise er enable that and I like to set
it to a blend of like I don't know 30
percent so that you're still getting a
little bit of that grain because I I
like it when you blur it out too much
when you do you know is it too much it
looks a little blurry and you lose
detail and we don't want to lose that
let's see also in the camera tab I'm
going to crank up the highlight
compression so
save a bit more of those highlights
let's see here saturation point nine
saturate two white point two usually so
when things basically when things are
like super super bright they'll lose
their saturation that won't be blue
anymore if you have like a really bright
blue light the source will still will
look more white it won't look blue so
the higher you crank this number the
quicker that white light or that blue
light turns to a white looking light
from the source what else we'll deal
with motion blur inside of After Effects
we want to choose the octane renderer
here in the octane renderer tab you want
to check use the D noised Beauty pass
because that way - like bacon the D
noise look into your actual image
sequence that you're gonna be rendering
out next when I'm setting up a render
obviously we're gonna save it right
we're gonna use probably an open EXR you
can also do PNG both of those have alpha
built in and that's very important for
what we're gonna do you want to make
sure that whatever you're rendering from
here has the background taken out or
alpha built in so that you can drop it
into your footage and after-effects
right so well for this sake we'll just
do PNG 8-bit is fine and you have to
have to have to check the alpha channel
box right there you won't get off a
channel unless you do that I'm gonna
save this let's save this here find your
right path
vegies sweet sweet okay
[Music]
let's render this sucker so this is your
little viewing window here if we do if
we go to filter I'm sorry if you go to
layer you can see the different layers
right so that you know if you check
single pass your alpha channel is
working properly
right so when I setup a renderer I
always make sure that I'm looking here
and this is working properly then you
have your background which has the you
know the bloom built in right because
the bloom I think is helping a lot with
that Sun streak so we're looking at
about 10 seconds per frame here we could
probably be going a little bit faster
but I'll leave it you know what no I'm
gonna speed this thing up I'm gonna stop
this and let's set our samples down to
150 and render again because we still
need to render a shadow pass after this
Pablo so you asked wouldn't highlight
compression lose highlight details know
when you slide the highlight compression
slider up it maintains the details so
when it's at zero its totally blown out
but when you slide it up to one it
maintains the highlight details so I'll
usually slide that all the way up and if
I want to composite it in after-effects
to better match the footage where other
highlights might be blown out I'll crank
those highlights back up in
after-effects so we're looking at like
seven seconds per frame here I'll let
this go for a little bit and then we'll
double back we'll set up our shadow pass
and then we'll hop in after-effects and
composite it together that'll be it oh
so now we got some Korean I cannot read
Korean working on that Japanese but I
don't have Korean down Sam do I usually
do a multi pass renderer uhm not
honestly not really like sometimes I'll
do the like post to bloom as a separate
pass in this case since I can't get
shadows working at the same time I will
in this case have to do shadows as a
separate pass but multi passes when you
render multiple passes at the same time
in this case I'm not doing that
and even for boss town dynamics we
didn't we didn't do that we just
rendered out the beauty pass of the
robot some times it came with we had to
render a separate shadow pass but
usually it was built like built and
baked in because it was all outside
um yeah I mean sometimes you'll do like
a ambient occlusion pass but I rarely
find myself myself using that in this
case maybe an ambient occlusion pass
would be all we all we would need for
the shadow pass but we'll mess with that
in a second
I don't think there's any subsurface
scattering on the vegetables right now I
think they're technically would be on
like the lettuce the carrots like maybe
on the tips but subsurface scattering is
basically when you have light filtering
through an object so like in this case
my finger light is coming through let's
see see if I can get this you say the
light is kind of filtering through my
fingernails yeah it's kind of hard to
see on the webcam but the light is
filtering through my fingernail a little
bit or like say for instance my ear
perhaps you see how the light is coming
through my ear that's subsurface
scattering and you'll see that in you
know a lot of legit renders and movies
like Gollum in Lord of the Rings has a
lot of that going on but when you're
going for realism that's certainly
something you want to consider in this
case you know we probably could have
gone the extra mile and done that but
you know this is a tutorial for tracking
and compositing stuff into your
live-action footage and while that
certainly is an element you know we
don't we don't need to go that far for
this for this case here
ha gamer 40:28 I really appreciate you
I'm glad that this helps out with your
exam no need to stress out all you have
to do is Google or YouTube how to do
this thing I'm looking to do and you'll
be alright so best of luck to you Simon
have I thought about switching software
um no not really
if anything would be to you know stream
and teach you guys blender stuff but
there's a lot of good blender guys out
there already and I'm very comfortable
in cinema 4d they actually sponsor us at
corridors so it's still free and same
for octane the octane sponsor so I don't
pay for that either
so that that's nice if I was paying for
it I'd probably be switching over but I
love the software it does everything I
needed to do so I'm just a big fan
zennith um man I better step it up then
that's that's pretty serious
I appreciate it that's awesome okay guys
I'm gonna stop the render here once we
get to 48 frames that'll be a full two
seconds I'll set up the shadow pass and
we'll render that out and we'll kompis
thing yeah
Pablo yeah we're still working in da
Vinci for editing I and I have mixed
feelings on it I'm so used to premiere
but I'll give it the honest try Johnny
it's a good point he says if you guys
don't find the exact tutorial you're
looking for try breaking down your
project into smaller tasks and search
for a tutorial that each task is set up
to accomplish that's a that's a good
idea yeah you know if you're looking to
do you know motion tracking you look up
motion tracking tutorials and you look
up texturing tutorials and eventually
all those things will build up into the
final effect you're trying to achieve
because right here we did a lot of stuff
we dealt with motion tracking we dealt
with building your 3d workflow we dealt
with a little bit of texturing not
really definitely a lot of navigation of
cinema 4d and After Effects we dealt
with lighting we dealt with cloners we
dealt with rendering setting up your
render and we're gonna about touch about
into compositing so that's a lot of
stuff that we just talked about here and
each one of those you can dive into and
find its tutorial on you know hundreds
of different tutorials on each one of
those little processes but hopefully
this guy's gives you guys a nice
overview and you can go out and find you
know different tutorials for different
parts of this process okay I'm gonna cut
this off let's set up our shadow pass
real quick so let's see I think this is
just like an ambient occlusion pass
that's all we need so um let's see we
went to frame 59 so we'll make sure
we'll render this as vegies underscore
shadow and we will go to frame 59
okay let's set up the shadow pass here
so what are we going to need
we can turn off the camera
imager or the post-process let's see
here let's hide our Sun okay and let's
turn our floor and our wall into shadow
catchers and then let's hide the the
objects here
where are our objects there we go I'm
going to add a octane object tag to the
veggies and turn off camera visibility
and that is our chat Oh pass right there
and honestly you can just use direct
lighting for this that's perfect that's
basically what we need so think
let's hit render on that and see how
long these frames take
yeah this will be glad to put carrots
and cabbage in your room tutorial using
After Effects and cinema 4d Sebastian
don't worry about spending any money on
tutorials and stuff just worry about
spending your time so if you download
blender and davinci those are two
programs that you can use blender is a
3d program DaVinci is an editor as well
as a compositor and a colouring you can
do sound in it too and export with those
two things you can you can do basically
anything you want for free look up those
tutorials and if you watch these streams
you can kind of get an idea for what you
need to look up and what you need to
Google so you know guys this shadow pass
here is taking far too long 18 seconds
per frame but you know what let's roll
with it let's go into After Effects and
start compositing this thing the final
touch the final step so if you
double-click in this window to the left
here you will pull up your little viewer
and all you need to do is go to your
image sequence of your vegetables wait a
second there we go
and just make sure you hit the check the
little PNG sequence button down towards
the bottom import that drop them in and
there you go there's some veggies
obviously doesn't look right because the
scale is off so what you could do is hit
shift F there's a way to like snap the
image it's a composition size let's set
that up real quick so basically
if you go to your keyboard shortcuts
under edit there should be an option to
like snap layer 2 composition size fit
layer took there there does fit layer 2
comp currently it's ctrl alt F I like to
change it to shift F boom and I'll snap
it to the proper you know the proper
size otherwise you can hit s and this
would probably be 300 yeah scale it up x
times 3 to get you to this final look
here so obviously they look like they're
floating because we don't have a shadow
but we can still bring in our shadow
even though it's still rendering so I'm
gonna do that as well make sure you
import the PNG sequence drop that in and
we'll do the same deal hit shift F and
basically if you set the shadow pass to
multiply it'll get rid of all the white
we keep the you know the darker colors
so let's just make sure that our white
is true white and not off gray and
certainly it is so I'm just throwing
levels on this thing if you go to the
little shadow layer you can go effect
color correction levels where there it
is and you can see this bar right here
that's basically where your gray tones
are you want to bring this far-right
slider up to meet that bar and that'll
turn these to white white you can you
can see by a your little info tab on the
top right if you just hover over the
white you can see this number 4 BB for
brightness it'll go up 200 before it was
probably at like yeah 82 so then when
you set this layer which we should name
we got veggies we got shadow
and if you set the mode to multiply
right up here you'll just have the
shadows right make sure you save guys
make sure you save yeah and there you go
so let's get into a little bit of
nitty-gritty compositing so first thing
I notice here zooming in is there's
motion blur on the footage itself you
guys can see this right it's a little
blurry it's not too crisp there's a
difference between this frame and this
frame this frame is blurry this frame is
not so we want you know that this this
render here obviously if we rendered it
at a higher resolution you'd really be
able to tell that it's more crisp you
know and but even still even still we
need to blur out the Surrender okay so
we want to match it when there's motion
blur in the footage we want to match it
here and I'm using a plug-in called real
smart motion blur if you guys are doing
this as a job that's the first thing you
should get is real smart motion blur
it's the best thing ever
basically all you have to do is select
your layer that you want to add motion
blur to and and certainly you can render
your stuff with motion blur in cinema 4d
or any renderer you have and it's better
to do it that way because it's the most
accurate motion blur but in this case we
don't have time I'm just gonna hit ctrl
spacebar and if you have Video Copilot
console VC console you have this little
box come up and please get VC console if
you're using After Effects it saves so
much time type in our SMB that stands
for a real smart motion blur boom so
like that and you can see the motion
blur was added to this footage and it's
like super accurate and it's the best
thing ever
it's actually a little blurry so I'm
gonna bring the blur amount down to like
point 4 that feels a bit more right
me let's see how our shadow pass is
doing if you go back to your little uh
your project tab here right click it and
hit reload footage you can see the layer
update down here down below and you just
have to slide that out and run actually
came up with a really cool trick if you
right-click the shadow layer or any
layer that is still rendering and you
need to keep updating and you go to time
enable time remapping and you take this
far-right keyframe and you slide it all
the way actually no I lied don't do that
don't do the the keyframe just take the
layer and slide it all the way out okay
to the length of your timeline and then
turn off time remapping and when you
right-click and you reload the footage
it's gonna update automatically you
don't have to keep sliding it out so
let's go in here you can see that like
the cabbage and the carrots they're
actually losing detail because of our
samples so I'm gonna throw a little bit
of sharpening on those things so we'll
take the veggies and we'll do just your
basic sharpen and we'll crank it to like
20 and make sure your blur your your
motion blur is going below all that okay
you're not trying to sharpen like well
okay you're trying to sharpen a low
resolution or a low sample render right
but you're not trying to sharpen a
motion blurred low resolution layer
right okay so you motion blur you want
you want that to be the last thing on
the list okay and then if you're getting
real technical about it which heck let's
get technical about it you want to add
back in any noise or grain that you're
live-action footage may have on it and
since this is a pretty bright scene here
we're not seeing much noise or grain
like maybe in here you can kind of see
it right
get real in there you can see that so if
you go to veggies and you do a match
grain effect and that should be your
last effect because when you motion blur
it right it's going to get rid of any
grain that even footage right it's gonna
get rid of any grain that that footage
might have so you're gonna want to add
the grain back on top and when
especially when compositing fake stuff
fake you know renders onto live-action
stuff you you want to add that noise
back into your render it's just gonna
add so under viewing mode will set it to
final output and then the noise source
layer we're referencing something you
want to reference your footage and there
you go it's there you can see before and
after is such a tiny it's such such such
a tiny little thing but it is certainly
a step in compositing your renders into
live-action footage next I think there
is like a white line around all around
this render and that it's just because
I've done it so many times that I know I
know it's there it's hard to tell but if
you go to veggies right click it and you
go to interpret footage okay so usually
comes in like this and you have to turn
select straight and that is going to get
rid of that white line but I didn't need
to do in that case so that's nice let's
update our shadow all right we're
getting closer and look at that the
motion blur is totally working on these
veggies and it looks awesome turn it on
and off for you guys to get an idea and
I think it's still a little bit much
so I'll set it to 0.3 how's everybody
doing we're basically at the end here
you can replace these vegetables with a
robot you can replace these vegetables
with a hole in the floor
you can replace these vegetables with
lava we did this video a long time ago
and it's one of my all-time favorites
but it's me Brett and cliff playing the
floors lava and this effect was done in
just after effects no cinema4d
and it was all using the after effects
3d tracker like we just did laying a
solid across the ground and then doing
like a little lava effect here and then
tracking in all these little flames
around the side of the couch or the wall
so this is no cinema 4d this is just
After Effects only using the after
effects 3d tracker and 3d solids you
know to get you this cool look or here
so you can get as imaginative as you
want with this stuff guys it doesn't
just have to be vegetables so let's see
what else can we do here am I missing
anything I think hmm
oh you see how the shadow is like taking
down the highlights oh whoa
we can probably crunch that in a little
bit let's take the shadow let's add
levels to it actually the shadow already
has levels on it let's go to alpha and
let's just kind of bring that in a
little bit
oh wait there's no alpha I lied go back
to RGB and just kind of bring bring
those shadows up a little bit we can
crunch crunch it down so it's a bit more
of a tighter shadow all right so we're
looking at something like this and I'm
just kind of bringing in the shadow a
little darker and then bringing in the
highlights and again that's on multiply
that feels pretty good to me
I think the darkest point in the footage
is 17 percent I'm looking at this be
alright
17 percent and the darkest point in the
render is 24 percent 18 percent that's
not that's not bad actually it's pretty
close
19 percent yeah that's pretty good hard
to do anything to this maybe it would be
saturation bring the saturation down a
little yeah something like that
and then we could go the extra mile on
this highlight and if you duplicate your
veggie layer and you can probably get
rid of all these effects and we'll add
an effect called extract and extract is
going to basically if I solo this if I
bring this slider down its gonna get rid
of all the dark stuff and if we just
want the bright points we can get those
right and then you have this other
little slider to feather out your
selection and with that on top you can
set that to like add or something and
you can see how that's like super bright
and you feather it right you can do like
a fast blur on that of like three or so
and you can see how that really brings
out the highlight you can set at the
screen which is basically the same as ad
but not as intense yeah and then I'll
get you a really nice hot highlight
right there very similar to this one
right here it's blown out you can see
the brightness is at 98%
and the same could be true here so we
might want to go up a little bit more on
that thing if we do set it to add and
take the opacity down to like maybe 50%
yeah I think it looks pretty sweet it
looks a bit more realistic
yeah let's um let's see what this thing
looks like let's reload our shadows
let's give this thing a bit of color the
shadow pass is almost finished we're
looking looking real good guys it's
looking really really close
let's pre-comp all of this stuff I'm
gonna hit control a to select all
control shift C to pre-comp it make sure
you move all attributes in the into the
new composition and let's just real
quick give it a little bit of color so
click ctrl alt shift why I lied I'm a
control shift why I lied again ctrl Alt
Y is what you want for an adjustment
layer and I'll just throw some like
basic levels on this thing give it a
little bit of contrast
I think the veggie brightness can come
up let's go back in here and let's
actually hear what you can do is copy
that adjustment layer paste it in here
and just make your adjustments from in
here
and let's see we'll do we'll just bring
up the levels here on the vegetables and
we'll make sure that levels is at the
bottom it's the first thing we want to
do is affect the color the sharpening
can come next the hue and saturation it
can actually come after the levels you
have all your color stuff first and then
you sharpen it and then you blur it and
then you have match screen on top which
I have hidden right now because it's
very render intensive so let's just
bring up the gamma for the veggies here
I'm just kind of like feeling this out
I think the shadows are a little intense
so I'm gonna just kind of drop those
down a little bit
and then we have this rogue cabbage back
here so I'm just gonna mask that out
real quick I'm hit G that's the pen tool
select it hit em that'll bring up your
mask options I'm going to animate my
mask clicking that little stopwatch and
I'm gonna hit shift page up and that
will jump back ten frames and I'll just
do this you know every 10 frames and
position the mask so it's on that last
little cabbage piece for all those
frames there it's a very quick way to
garbage matte something out all right 1
2 3 4 5 you basically get the in-between
frames so now I'm going basically just
did every 5 frames and then I'm doing
the same process again just to make sure
and we'll set that mass to subtract and
now that cabbage is gone you'll want to
do the same thing for the shadow we can
copy that mask paste it on the shadow
and since your layer size is the same
that cabbage is gone updating our shadow
again our shadow is done looking nice
and good I'm going to duplicate the
shadow and set the duplicate layer to
50% opacity
sweet yeah that's looking awesome will
hide the adjustment layer and let's just
give it a little little vignette so hit
ctrl Y make it black solid and if you
hold down this little square rectangle
tool you can set it to the lips and if
you double click that it'll perfectly
make an ellipse mask around the size of
your composition I'll set it to subtract
hit f4 feather set it to like 200 set it
to 500
control shift H again to hide all of
your layers and guides and I'll set the
mode to overlay and hit T bring it down
to 50% opacity I always like a little
bit of vignette and let's see what that
looks like I think we did a good job
here guys
thank you guys for joining the stream
this was the longest one yet three hours
we did it thank you so much we put some
vegetables in our house it's looking
nice and beautiful yeah if you guys have
any questions
I made a discord group for all of us the
link to that is in the description of
this video so be sure to sign up for
that what else yeah I got an ambient
playlist if you guys want to hop onto
that on Spotify and work on VFX or do
homework or whatever you can listen to
that it's super chill again if you guys
are looking for a way to help support
the process here I do have a website
where I have photos from all across the
world I got Japan China Beijing
Indonesia Taiwan Ireland is the latest
place we've been to it's all film
photography some digital photography as
well and I try to get the prices down as
low as possible for you guys my prints
looks super nice and I sign it and you
know write a little note on the back and
everything get it to everybody pretty
quick shipping is pretty cheap if this
is a little too pricey for you then oh
snap so we're in dude yes okay so that
is a what is that called a super chat
Zorin thank you so much for your
donation I really really really
appreciate it yeah that you're you're
the first person ever to do super chat
so let's do something real quick in
cinema D cinema 4d for you
let's do mo texts and you'll say thank
you Zorin boom for the super chat yeah
so I just enabled that thing and it's a
way for you guys to help help donate and
help get your chat you know in things
this first time I've been doing this and
yeah just enabled it today I think it's
super cool and let's see if we can't add
like a glassy kind of deal with this
maybe do like a a chrome thank you
letter to Zoran for the very kind
donation and we'll get like make it bold
right you know a little something a
little sweet little little sign there
but thanks dude
really appreciate it yeah that was a
that was a good session guys I hope you
learned a lot and I will be back next
week next Saturday at noon pacific
standard time with another tutorial for
you guys if you have suggestions for
tutorials go to the discord leave a
little suggestion there and this was
actually one of the your guys's
suggestions so thank you so much
i'll catch you guys on the next one and
until then stay passionate and stay
excited and i'll see you guys later
peace